oh my God it's coming guys it's coming
it's coming it's coming it's coming and
go going it's coming it's Go-Go I mean
it comes so hard please don't say that
please Esther can't handle it she's
gonna slush and slash off that seat
we're talking about our live stream show
which is Wednesday March 30th at 6 p.m
Pacific and we want you to get your
tickets at momenthouse.com trash Tuesday
it's going to be such a mistake yeah
it's really wild but you know but so
many of you guys have already signed up
for tickets like I said do not miss this
what can we expect a career low
ultimately a career level a career high
for me because I feel like my career is
watching your lows and a big old come
for me
we have plans the things that I've heard
that we're doing are making me so
uncomfortable that I just can't help but
grin and just we'll get through it we'll
get our Bell for her we'll see you guys
there get tickets at momenhouse.com
trash Tuesday and clear your schedule
for Wednesday March 30th because it's
gonna You're Not Gonna Wanna Miss it 6
p.m PST see you guys there
hi slugs welcome to another episode of
ow that hurt
my nose is still burning from what
happened earlier guys some some sniffing
happened I don't think it was wild there
was running screaming this is a good
episode but FYI Annie and I are stand-up
comedians and we are on the road and we
are so excited we can't wait to meet you
guys we're gonna tell you where we're
gonna be I'm gonna be in Philadelphia
April 1st and 2nd April 6th I'll be in
San Diego then I'm going to Austin Texas
Brooklyn Washington DC Minnesota Chicago
and I even added a date in Los Angeles
get tickets at Esther onice.com anywhere
you headed I am going to San Francisco
in April I'm going to Syracuse New York
in April I'm going to back to Florida
I'm going I'm also having a show in
Burbank soon I'm gonna be in Austin
Texas I'm going to be at a really fun
casino in California I'm gonna be in
Tempe Arizona and many more go to
annieleterman.com shows it's been so
crazy have just started signing ball
sacks too it's so fun I'm a scrotum
signer you never know what's going to
happen it's been absolutely Wild
[Music]
I woke up this morning okay I opened the
door to my apartment
okay I see in the stairwell I see
a dirty blanket and pillow and like a
sack like like it's like a human [ __ ]
pile and I thought where's that story
right now
so that's her sleep on my stoop that is
so Esther Vibes like a dirty blanket and
pillow if you see that you know I'm not
far usually in Todd kicking it down the
stairs with his Yeezys and they're just
like turds rolling out I'm like did you
guys grow up with a binky
no is this gonna turn into dick sucking
how
baby I had a binky I also had my twin
brothers you know but it's only a binky
if you keep it around for years right I
had a blankie yeah wait a blankie then
that's a binky I think that's the sucker
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm not from here I always
thought a binky was something like a a
cloth material you kept until adulthood
that's a blankie do you have a blanket
you're teaching her English that was
cute that is Blinky do you guys have
blankies I mine has has disappeared
through life but I had it for a long
time same I know where mine disappeared
when I was at the hospital for a surgery
they my family got lost there and it's a
sore subject there's like a nurse who
hate I know there's like a person's face
you're thinking of no it's my parents
fault I blame them actually no I'm I
should take responsibility when I was 11
it was my fault
um but my best friend from college Lena
who is my age 34 33 whatever she still
has her blankie
um
I like that I know it's like a form of
comfort I I think it's like something
maybe you could like give to your kids
or something but it's mine was like mine
was a sleeping bag that we got at Toys R
Us that was like it was Care Bears but
it was very soft like it I had worn it
into softness well that's why they're
yeah like they're amazing is because you
wear them down it's just like a vintage
softest blanket in the world it was a it
was a rag though by the end it was not
wait this is inspiring me I want to get
a shirt and I want to wear it every day
and like cuddle it if I when I sleep and
then turn it into a blanky shirt oh boy
just the pheromones the smells the
stench of it all I
um I remember my dad I must want to call
him and confront him actually let me
call my dad and ask him about my blankie
what he almost did to my blankie Esther
Coffee thank you so much that was so
quick how did you do that Esther for you
to get it that soft fast you're gonna
have to have Annie and I wear it to
sweat in it yes I think our sweat um
speeds up the the thinning and soft
softening process the color bright it
looks so good look at the color
it looks hi Dad I'm on my podcast
say hi to Scotty hi Scotty body Scotty
he's all legs
um he's nervous okay they just asked if
we had a blankie when we were little and
I just had a memory of do you remember
what we almost did to my [ __ ] blankie
he almost took my blankie when I was
sleeping and made it into a teddy bear
I would have been
when you were on your own at 13.
that's amazing you were grown
no yes
blankie's gone dead
oh you're trying to out me like I still
have blankie
these [ __ ] still have theirs
this is a regression podcast wait while
we have your dad yes do you have any
questions Mr Letterman what is I'm just
curious like what do you think of of
Annie
I think is a an amazing human being he
is continuing to grow in in love and
comedy and I'm proud of her
as proud as any Dad could be of his
daughter absolutely oh I love you Daddy
thank you for the slave verbal abuse as
a child that turned me this way yes we
we all need that I have no resentments
anymore I just love my parents it's so
cool I was thinking that the other day
with my mom I was like I'm not even mad
at this [ __ ] anymore I used to always
be like a little like [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I like let her read me some of her books
she wrote and I want to tell you the big
one is it's not about me she wrote a
book that did not have me in it at all
how do I feel that is a problem
well she's still editing it no no no no
if my name gets in it she gets a slap
slap slap yeah
she'll be struck
it is and from the 1850s so you're in it
Dad
well I I was a younger man
what year is your dad born yeah what
year were you born dad
1941 don't pause like that that scares
us uh well
well
I can't believe our dads
what's your age at the top of the
medical form yeah it says 80. I thought
it was just 80 pages of notes about what
a cycle you are there's 800 pages
all right I have to go but is that Mom
yeah just have mom say hi because we
have to get on with it
hi Annie hi Mom
mom Esther wants to ask you a question
about me I think I've already asked your
mom this but ask her again Mrs Letterman
Esther wants to ask you a question
you're on the podcast I'm just curious
what do you what's your current opinion
of Annie
uh she has a great life that is
judgmental that's very 3D wow and great
Friends Podcast
I don't know she's lying my mom said to
me not too long ago she goes I think
podcasts are so boring and I go I didn't
know you listen to podcasts what podcast
do you listen to she goes just yours
I'm like that's weird it's the only
podcast that talks [ __ ] on you I wish my
parents thought this was boring I'm
jealous of you her parents watch every
episode anyway I love you Mom
bye Mama bye dad
thank you yeah go find me a new blankie
love you
we need to do the old men of trash
Tuesday and do my dad your dad and your
stepdad what do you mean or just like
they should be I was like wait a minute
my dad's ashes just sitting here oh
that's actually so funny and sad but
funny you're funny we make it anime we
animate the mouth
swim [ __ ] swim
Annie is that a Louis Vuitton bag it is
I was waiting for you to notice where
did you get that tell us everything is
at the mall and I I made a decision once
I said if I go into the store I gotta
leave with something
now I'll tell you what I did to make it
okay give it to me now well please
describe this whole outfit give us the
wait also this is a Chic as [ __ ] cool
Louis Vuitton no I'm gonna bring yeah
Carlos's mom has it yeah then you know
it's really nice it says everything like
honestly everything Todd likes is ruined
because Carlos always has it like you
guys have to teach me yeah you'll be
like God damn it Carlos he's like I
can't get them
Carlos's family is a spoiler of the
exciting things because they're so rich
they got the things first we're the only
two things in Annie's purse are Kylie
lip kits and a passport what's going on
she's out of your [ __ ] I'm taking us
to Bali now
we're going on vacation I just like
bring can you please teach me about
purses I'd have no clue I've never
bought a single like name brand purse in
my life I'm the same way but I will say
something holding this like the woman in
me is coming out like I it looks great
on you too it really does it's such a
little cute baby I wasn't so I went in
and then so what I was thinking was I
wanted to like really be flashy for this
party so I went to the wait what party
okay so I went to the independent Spirit
Awards after party was not invited I was
like I'm getting in oh that's because
you okay well I was invited by Bonnie
okay Bonnie McFarland was the head
writer of the independent Spirit Awards
however you're the only one that cares
no one else cares people like writers
what are you talking about like nobody
cares like a backpack it was the
funniest thing that's so badass so
Bonnie there's so many pretty ones look
they're getting cute again I don't like
the brown like the cheapest regular ones
3 400 Annie how much was that this
wasn't this was like 17. oh okay this
was I I felt like I was paying my old
Ren and I'm gonna give it my the way I I
decided to get it was I know that Todd's
mom will really want it so I'll give it
to her in like a couple months I'll try
I'll test drive it for her yeah so I
wanted to go to this Awards and we were
at the mall and I just like I I always
know I'm gonna find the outfit I want
and I found this was like this was not
that expensive but I found this at
Nordstrom's my stockings are showing I'm
wearing green shorts because I thought
maybe you could green screen something
cool coming out of my mesh
she's never not thinking I'm always
there's always something
um but then yeah so I just got this
outfit and
um Bonnie was like yeah come just say
that you guys are writers and I was like
say we're writers to the movie star
place so Todd and I show up
and it's like you know it's full
confidence to get into something you're
not invited to so we're like full
confidence Todd's wearing jeans I'm like
Todd you do Todd looked like a pilot on
his demo he had like a nice jacket with
like fur but it was like he looked like
he was like pilot on the day off is kind
of a look I did get wet just saying that
honestly horny there's going to be a
little sticky spot on this why is that
so hot like there's something I
definitely tried to [ __ ] Pilots before
like I've been at the I've been I've
I've left feelers like at the they've
never been on my radar they're never hot
I feel like you always you have to be in
first class you're closer to them here's
what I think about men in uniform it's
it's like you can't fall in love with
them while they're in uniform because
you have no idea or you can't like suss
out their style in real life I know but
what if they show up to your date in
like on ironic cargo shorts like in a
dad style
dad's style pilots on off they will wear
that they're they're going to be fathers
on on the off they also will have
another family
so you do have to consider a couple of
those things I have to say the [ __ ]
I ever get in my life is when I'm
leaving a plane and I look at the pilot
and I go thank you and I go where's your
parent little unaccompanied minor like
where's your little um pass
did you ever do that did you guys ever
travel like by yourselves when you're a
kid and have to have them they have to
walk they have to like kind of babysit
you well it's funny you should ask
because you know what answer I'm gonna
give which is that I wasn't a minor but
my dad pretended I was so that he could
go in with me and drop me off but I was
probably like 22. oh I want to see if we
can do that now I bet there's like
Paparazzi I bet he could still do that
now yeah I still when I'm at the airport
I still will get asked are you over the
age of 13. I Really Wanna let's like
let's go out into the world and like
test what we can get away with we will
go far we will go very far I I went to
Indonesia by myself when I was 12. what
and I had a raging fever and I was
miserable for two weeks without my mommy
or dad who took care of you when you
were sick
um the team doctor
get the Bell the Monster Ball good cut
to the rainbow screen we're having
technical difficulties we should have
like a molested rainbow screen that we
can put up like whenever it's just like
a like
I had my own personal Larry Nazar I know
like oh you know his name I don't pay
attention like trigger are you kidding
me when I watch that documentary or
anything involving those gymnasts uh you
you must have been so fully my sister
and I just like I just we can't handle
it no I can't watch there's a show
there's a um what was it called
[ __ ] it came out like four years ago it
was about teachers that banged I was
like I will die if I watch this my head
will explode if I watch that what
happened to me happened but I remember
what triggered me was the mother was the
one telling the girl that she was
molested and she was like no no I liked
them and I was like that was me
convincing me I'm like it's not okay for
teachers to [ __ ] their kids it's not
okay not that they're like that anymore
I love my parents who saw them they're
beautiful
wait that is so you guys just cannot
watch something like that like it would
just not if it's very specific to what
happened to me especially a team doctor
yeah if it's sports or Sports involved
exactly I'll say this I that I was not
molested like that but there's still
time but I also feel very uncomfortable
watching and hearing about that doctor
that famous doctor but at the same time
like I have so much respect for those
girls yeah and it's important story to
be told it's just
Michael Jackson he could be innocent I
never watched it I have no clue what's
the documentary about is it about how to
moonwalk I thought it was an
instructions on how to moonwalk I like
Block it's horrible that's smart of you
I know I just know from seeing comedians
tell bits of it on stage I've just
pieced it together where I I go I think
he might have been a bad guy he might
have been a bad guy I wanted to say
something about how like I am coming in
with all this like expensive stuff
because I feel like there's a qualifying
thing I need to say
and you guys know this and a lot of the
people that follow us know this but some
people don't I lived in my car like
three years ago like this is like a very
big deal for me I was broke as [ __ ] I
believe did I I had a little inkling
that I could do it
um and I would you know but I really
just wanted to do comedy so I wasn't
willing to let's change but I used to
um say Tesla 2020. if you go back to my
mean inspiration episodes my solo
podcast you can see how broke I was I
was like on this little chair there was
like Construction in the background
there's nothing I could do and um I do
like to like it's fun to be getting all
these things and stuff but I do want you
guys to know that if you like you know
anything is possible but here's what I
thought I thought you were gonna say
don't try this at home don't definitely
don't try this at home like I'm not
putting things like on credit cards I
can't pay and stuff like I am making
sure I can do this yeah and you have a
business manager I have a business
manager I have like a tour like I have
yeah you're you're I know it's like hard
here's what I'll say about you that I
really love is you have big no plan B
Energy and that's what Bobby says that's
he he always says that's what it takes
to make it here is not have a plan B to
be so just hyper focused on one thing
and not think about anything else or how
[ __ ] up your life could be if it
doesn't work out but just be so dude
it's true when I was in high school I
remember I was talking to my theater
teacher like just trying to figure out
what my major would be in college and he
said something I'll never forget it he
said if you have a plan B you'll use it
and I was just like okay that's out then
there's no place is that after he just
inside you no it's not his sexual
preference but thank you for how much
does that cost these days the plan B I
don't know they used to be like what 50
bucks I used to love those I was like oh
I gotta I got 72 hours of jizz in me I
know I go three days of cream pie is
what I used to call it hold on hold on
it's like My Week with Marilyn
hold on
like you have the accident okay you have
the accident and then after that then
you get the pill but you have 72 hours
right it just creeps like let's go now
let's go go can I offer let's go go
offer up a different perspective
isn't the plan B like bad for you like
you don't want to just be taking it it
doesn't matter but if you're gonna have
to go through it already you don't plan
it ahead of the gym the mistake happens
okay the mistake happens you're like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to take it yeah let
me enjoy my my last it's like your last
supper it's just basically how Bobby
describes surf and turf it's it's how
Bobby describes rehab it's like I'm not
gonna be the first guy on this planet to
show up to rehab sober he's like I'm
gonna show up with a [ __ ] stop sign
wrapped around my neck so basically it's
like once the thing happens it's like a
really good Halloween costume if you
guys want to be Bobby stop sorry
but it's a good point Annie and you know
probably very irresponsible of us but
it's a cream pie party you have to look
for the it's like what we're just
talking about with money you have to
look at the good things you can't look
at the negatives okay I'm about to [ __ ]
my body up with this pill
I might as well make it worth it might
as well feel the the warmth inside oh
God the warmth the warm the warm release
inside I think I just get so angry and
this is my own issue but like guys who
accidentally do that I'm just like
you're not allowed that's unacceptable
to me it does depend on their age
like if they're like way older than me
I'm like you've had enough time
and those sperms are slow we know you
had a lot of warning I have a really
crazy theory that I'm just or is it a
theory or just a take I don't know I
want to put this out there I know it's
going to be controversial I think that
no one should have sex until they turn
30. because I think that sex before 30.
is never that good you're insecure I
don't think it's worth your time okay I
agree with that and I have been maybe
even quoted saying that but I will say
this
I think now looking back you need all
these [ __ ] up experiences you need all
these not knowing what you're doing and
stuff to build you into the person that
can understand
imagine being with just a bunch of 30
year olds who don't know how to [ __ ]
what was like your 30th birthday like
all your guy friends like I got your
present it's planned they'll come in two
seconds they have no come control
they're all [ __ ] inside you for you
know by accidentally then maybe maybe
okay pivot but I like this I know what
you mean because it's like you're maybe
not emotionally ready for sex until I
used to say when I was 27 I'm not real I
go I'm not ready like I really felt that
way what about we women I mean the real
the honest pitch is that you just don't
[ __ ] guys under 30. I think that's but
that is a problem that will lead to a
problem I don't know because I now have
flipped and now I'm dating Todd who's
under oh my God wait that's crazy how to
be a virgin I'd be waiting for him still
patiently waiting masturbating could you
oh by the way I have a new term Todd and
I came up with this Todd did and I want
to push it okay
instead of flicking the bean because
there's not good like jerking off for
girls
giving a cookie noogie give yourself a
cookie that is so cute can we make
cookie Nokia thing I'm just throwing it
out there if no one takes it I'm okay no
these are a little painful it's yeah
that's it's but we're not we're I'm not
flicking my beanie no that's looking a
bean makes no sense
yeah it's a soft little also it's like
turning on a button usually for me like
plugging something in
I'm a little lazy let's just say I skull
[ __ ] myself too
that's not like I'm but I'm just saving
it for when I'm alone imagine if you
were that type of masturbator that got
off on like being skull [ __ ] so you
would you know masturbate but you have
to like blow your own the others you'd
have to have a double headed one and
you're blowing it while it's going in
you
I wonder it's like a human centipede
every time Annie says double-headed I'm
just like I need to get my Bell because
I don't know why I know I love you not
even but you have a spray thing
oh my God I brought something for us oh
wait another thing I wanted to say about
the money and me like being Flash and
stuff right now it's also it's not I'm
very excited about the money it's very
very exciting my goal has never been
money and I think that's one of the
reasons it took me so long to make it
because I had to believe that I was like
worth making money because it was so far
down on my like list of values I just
always wanted to be funny tell the truth
and like have fun so those do not
include money those do not money does
not necessarily come with that but I had
to kind of like retrain my subconscious
for that but the main thing that I love
is like the connecting with the audience
I know this sounds like [ __ ] but I
like love that we're reaching people I
love that that's happening and it feels
like an even exchange when I make my
money it doesn't feel like I'm not like
selling nfts unless you're on Twitter
for that 48 hours that you got hacked
but like you know what I mean like I
don't I have no interest in like
tricking anyone or like scamming anyone
like I really want to like
you know I just want everything to be
like an even flow
[Music]
30 million women are impacted by weak
and thinning hair why did you say it at
us like that because we have thinner
hair than you you said it's so rude no
you yes no I actually did Esther do you
know how many different clips and tracks
I've had to put in my hair that is why
we've got you love it on neutrophone I'm
on it my four pills a day baby I take it
kalila takes it Dave takes it I think
doesn't Bobby take it too we all take it
there's one person that we're not
allowing to say they take it until the
results come in
I was exposed to chlorine for so many
years so by the time I turned 30 and
with some hormonal changes my hair just
started falling off and I never like men
there's so many things about men losing
their hair they don't talk about women
no you don't I didn't even think about
it until it started happening to me your
hair ages and then I think back when I
think about my mom's hair is like gotten
a little bit like the textures my mom's
always had thicker hair than me and so
neutrophil is my chance to finally beat
my mom at the hair game look guys it's
all all natural ingredients and this
isn't an overnight fix this is some and
that this is how I know it's legit if
you take it as adjusted in a couple
months you really will see the results
and your baby hairs will grow up and
turn into adults Wow first grade
in a clinical study 86 percent of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months and more than 1500 Top Doctors
recommend neutrophil as an effective and
high quality solution for healthier hair
and they're just vitamins they're good
for you too so it's like they also don't
have that vitamin burp taste it's like
they're just it's it's a win I love them
I took them today before I came you can
grow thicker healthier hair and support
our show by going to neutrophil.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get 15 off at
neutrophone.com that's spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com slash trash
ET tutu I love attitude but like I love
the sheets so much I have them in navy
blue and I have them in a light green I
absolutely love these sheets they're
made from bamboo which is very cooling
but so silky soft as our own our
resident koala bear is very happy about
this well here's what people don't don't
know cotton is incredibly wasteful and
has a very damaging crop that uses
dangerous pesticides and drains the
Earth's water supply
um and bamboo is literally softer it's
cleaner and it's better for the
environment I think these sheets are way
more breathable too I I run hot when I
say yes me too so these bamboo sheets
are a godsend I like to keep the wet
spot right at the crotch area I don't
want it to be up near the neck and stuff
I definitely think if you're looking to
invest in your sleep and having a nice
experience these are my favorite sheets
and I have I've been I've tried a lot of
sheets okay you guys know me I'm a bed
expert and right now you can get 20 off
your order plus free shipping when you
visit attitude.com Tuesday spelled e t t
i t u d e.com slash Tuesday this is
attitude's best offer but don't wait
it's only for a limited time order today
for free shipping and 20 off your order
at attitude.com Tuesday and let us know
if you like them I love them they're so
soft remember guys bamboo is better in
the bed
foreign
[Music]
talking about your party that you
crashed oh my God crash the parties
sorry because I know I got a text I got
a text from Sterling hardjoe who um is
the writer and director for res dogs on
Hulu that won a bunch of award like I
was like she wanted everything I'm like
dude I was like you should come on and
break the statues and then leave
the statues can you imagine if there's
just two statues in the chairs but but
they won they killed it yeah well he
texted me he was like oh my God I just
hung out with Annie please have her send
me the pictures and then you sent me the
pictures to send to him because I kept
being like I'll text her but I was kept
I was like in a party I was like I'm
starting I'm not ready
I'm I'm still feel I'm in it so anyway
so we we go to get in
now I don't know why
it didn't occur to me that writers are
not considered human like if you're
behind the camera nobody gives a [ __ ]
George
um no but like was it fun joke
um I don't know this one finagled on a
camera but
um okay so we're standing outside we
don't get in like we get the first round
we get like a band and we're like oh
we're one of the birds like okay great
so they give us this band they check our
vaccine cards we go to a next one they
go okay your name I'm like Letterman
they're like um could it be under
anything else and I go no it would be
under a letterman and they're like David
okay yeah and they actually like what's
funny is they they misheard me and they
go oh like Emily and I went no I just
like can't lie I can only lie so much
you know so I was like no I was like oh
I'm with the writers which was the truth
and they were like oh there's no writers
on here and I was like that's so funny
because Bonnie hadn't gotten there yet
she's like we're coming in a shuttle The
Writers come out still in writer gears
everyone else is in gowns okay I'm like
I look like I went to like can Tempo
casual and in 1998 but it's back so I'm
I'm totally fine with the fact that I
just like my exact 13 year old self
but so Todd and I are there and Todd was
wearing jeans and I'd been like don't
wear jeans but I was like the fact that
we're not getting in and you're in jeans
is like way better than if he was in a
suit right we're getting in but so we
just hovered in the area that we had
gotten into like I wasn't gonna give I
wasn't gonna go back
out of like I wasn't going to give
another opportunity for them so I just
we stayed hovered in this area and the
security kept coming over and we just I
go Todd stand up we're just oh we're
just waiting for our supervisor to come
blah blah blah they roll out in their
backpacks they have full keyboards I'm
like you guys brought keyboards to the
party like you didn't think to like
leave them in your car like get hair and
makeup to show you guys up like hats
like they've been like bustling their
ass writing this thing every day for
like three weeks so they're like so
tired
how it's like oh my God you guys are the
ones that are gonna like grab a [ __ ]
tray we're gonna have to say we work
here
but but Bonnie made it happen we all go
in and
um you know I was like it was hard
because it was starting to get dark and
it's hard to like you know wear your
sunglasses in the dark I was like
tripping over things and
um what's her name Fox uh Julian Fox was
there and I didn't get a picture with
her and I want to [ __ ] she was did
you talk to her at all I was going
towards her and then I was like you know
what I'm just gonna get a drink first
and then she was gone I should have
known she was just coming in to do a I
feel like Julia Fox would love you I
know she would and I already had my plan
I was gonna go never change I love how
you enunciate things do not change
everything you're doing is perfect and
keep the shoes she had the Kanye boots
and I go wear them every day you think
she'd do our show yes she would be so
she would fit in so well amongst us
freaks like it would be awesome I was so
and but it was a good lesson I'm looking
at everything as nothing's bad it's just
a lesson and the lesson is you always
pounce on it if Esther was there she
would have poked me into her I would
have forced you you would have forced me
that's why we're a good Duel at parties
because I just because I am and you
can't but you also can get in like you
can like climb into because like crawl
spaces
you can I'm like you go over and talk to
the kids now it looks creepy if I talk
to them I sneak through the air vent I
go around to the other side of the park
and then I catch you yeah
no I really almost needed like a broom
to sweep into that [ __ ] but it was a it
wasn't embarrassed like I was like just
stand like when people were coming in
and I was like I was seeing people I
know I was like okay and like oh yeah
I'm like yeah just waiting just waiting
for someone but then I got in I saw
Sterling was like Annie
um he's like oh my God it's me from
because I remember from Bobby's right
there and he's like I love your podcast
I was like you gotta come on I texted
someone I don't know who it was maybe
someone that doesn't isn't on the
podcast I just texted my dad so let's
try to get him on but next time but it
was so fun to talk to him and like I was
just watching people because I was
trapped out so I was watching I almost
had my own red carpet because I was just
watching People's outfits and um and
then I saw yeah I just kept like seeing
people like I saw one guy was like
you're on my Instagram like it was just
fun like once I was in I belonged it was
good and um and then some guy came up to
me I just want to let you guys know
trash Tuesday has gone Hollywood okay
because some guy goes I heard are you
Andy Letterman from trash Tuesday I'm
like I've been working my ass off for 13
years this is the only thing people know
me for
but he was like I was like he's like I
heard your voice I knew it had to be you
he's like sorry if this is like weird I
know all these things I'm like no it's
fine I like it and um he works at HBO
Max so they're watching hello HBO Max I
don't remember your name Mr HBO Max but
if you do want to email me
that is so cool that guy Sterling his
show is so incredible I was just so cool
I was just in Santa Barbara opening for
Mark Marin this weekend and he was
singing his Praises like saying how is
so incredible well what I like is he was
saying is like I've been cast I cast
Bobby he goes I guess
I was like and I went
hello
we're here hi we gotta do we need to
[ __ ] imagine it's a show it's a show
about
um indigenous people living in the res
and then just all white people cast yes
no the white people that come and run it
I lived in New Mexico I lived that left
do you think I wasn't
The Stumbling drunk white girl on the
right original things
but it was really fun and it was cool
that everyone like knew us it was
awesome that's like inspiring me I want
to like throw I want there to be some
sort of cool Hollywood party that the
three of us can go to and be like where
let's just
crashing let's crash all the parties
okay because it's more fun to be invited
is kind of no it was amazing because it
was like people did see us standing
there because remember how fun it used
to be well at least for me to go into a
club or a bar underage
your shitty ID Works you're like [ __ ] it
it stops being fun drinking when she
turned 21. right like what are you guys
talking we're looking for a thrilled
Esther's like when I'm 51 and I finally
decide to drink a look at alcohol wait
look it's award season is it not yeah
let's crash
okay okay HBO Max guy if you can help us
out with this you know that this all
ends like with like Dave at some party
and us just humiliating him oh yeah no
Dave's invited we're not yes
it has a big jacket I finally confessed
to him this last night but I have had
this dream for years but because of
covet I realized it's probably never
going to happen but he has this weekly
poker game that he goes to at this guy's
house and I I've always had like a
couple Mutual girlfriend like who
friends who would could potentially be
invited to his poker night so I had this
plan that I was gonna dress in like a
costume where you couldn't see me at all
like hoodie whatever sunglasses and just
like spy on Dave of the poker were you
outside my house
taking a [ __ ] on my doorstep Esther
paint the picture so is he just hanging
out with four or five of these of his
buddies and you're just gonna be in a
corner somewhere can I have a request
you after this that you maybe tell your
biggest story again even though this
yeah and everyone watch her special too
but it's in my stand-up special I don't
even remember but okay watch the special
yes but I did I did Uninvited show up to
Dave's bachelor party in Las Vegas and
it did not go over well there's a reason
there's no wedding yet it's still a
story I'm not sure still a very
uncomfortable subject in our home
um but so the poker game is like a
rotating crew I feel like of like eight
to twelve guys and you know I feel like
there are certain people that will go
who don't normally go like it's kind of
chill enough that where I feel like I
could show up
completely covered and like hang back
and just completely understand your
height is so
anything walking in your height
everyone's gonna go what is that whether
your face is showing or not
that's so funny you say that because
this weekend someone referred to me on
the street as a little critter when a
random person just said that it was one
of Mark's fans like was like oh you were
great and then she looked at me she's
like you work great too you Little
Critter you are a little critter
I kind of like received that very well I
know a guy um who goes by Critter but
he's like a big like mountain man I got
scared like when you say I don't know
why I was like I'm scared he's the
sweetest sweetest guy ever but his name
is Critter and he actually used to um do
a show with David Cho oh uh but you guys
would make a cute Duo Critter and Little
Critter
Chris and Critter oh she's a critter
wait Esther do you know how to play
poker
um I have not played since high school
okay
so it's been a moment but Carlos can
play for her you'll be on a team
is that a girl urge to be like teams
like a team and poker so that's very
like that's a scary thing to pick to you
know what I mean to choose teams and to
not be the Chooser of your own team oh
to have just someone yeah because you
know to be the last person picked on the
team like that's a big thing in my
family because that's why I'm always a
captain because I never want to be the
last to be picked so don't you say go
pick me pick me pick me pick me get it
that is me girl joke I am always so
comfortable in my zone of being the last
one selected like you almost have made
your whole life like let me just let you
know I'm cool this yeah every every move
you've made so slowly in real life has
been to go let's I'm just gonna take
myself out of this yeah because I call
us in gym class of course I was always
picked last I was the smallest the
weakest did everything you were the ball
and dunk you
I was always the girl in gym class who
got hit on the head with a ball and then
of course used even though it didn't
really hurt use it as an excuse to go to
the nurse's office did you ever play
dodgeball did you ever I played but she
was in a Dodge once yeah I just gym
class was not where I thrived where did
you thrive in the hallways
in the locker room baby
in the locker
hiding in the locker looking through the
slots at the boobies I'm not even
kidding I remember being excited that we
were all gonna change together you
aren't listen there's a lot of
controversy in the comments that Porsha
reads
um that's about whether you're really
gay and I honestly do not don't know how
to explain it to you guys
I've known her for over a decade a
decade and a half she is looking at
women's bodies
99.9 of the time
it's such a it's so it's like I refuse
almost to comment on it because I'm like
my sexuality is my business and people
can it's actually our business
three ways
um I brought something for you guys to
try I'm ready okay I don't know if you
are uh-oh Todd ordered and I didn't even
know these existed smelling salts have
you done smelling salts before
swimming and stuff oh Dave uses this one
he faints how often does he faint every
time he watches his podcast
Esther you have a fainting you have a
fainting fan
administered on yourself after you think
uh I think that's a good question he's
making paintings about to faint well how
often
what makes him so dizzy so sleepy are
you telling him a story yes is that what
he's watching her special
has health issues should we ask him call
him what is the health issue situation
have you have you ever tried them the
smelling salt oh no I have a missed call
from my dad that is so not good no I'm
Dave has warned me that I shouldn't try
the smelling salt why because they're
really strong that's what's gonna happen
I don't know you're gonna have an
experience in life and realize you were
fine
oh I tried to use
um
my Esther and I are conversation the
other day about
um trying new things I try to use that
against her to manipulate her into
hanging out later and it didn't work
that was funny you're like duh and I was
like okay she he was trying to get me to
go to the next comedy club with her
after then I was you'd I was like don't
you want to try a new thing she was like
stop you were weaponizing with her
little hand her little hand hey Dave
so hi you're on the podcast Annie has
smelling salts and it made me think of
you
why do you use why do you have a new
smelling salts
one I'm very happy to answer while the
shopping is Gelson's
[Laughter]
Gelson's fancy
and when I
went out so I need smelling salts to
help revive me there couldn't be
anything actually scarier than passing
out when a needle is being put into your
arm that's actually scarier than the
needle okay we continue oh look how cute
Dave is thank you for the info I love
that
um that Dave's like thing that he needs
for his health is you and Todd's like
fun it's just me I go alone let me see
oh this you mean IVs yeah I'm like oh do
IVs bother you I'm like come on you know
they don't bother me the the one thing
that bothers me is if I don't watch the
needle go away have you tried it yet I
look away I don't like it I have to look
it because I have to know if I don't
know the source of the pain then I get
anxious okay if I know exactly where the
pain is coming from then it makes sense
to me then I can I'm fine that's
interesting because I always think about
that like with Todd gets really really
much did you terrible motion sickness I
didn't know you weren't supposed to open
it that's what they give to NFL players
when they get concussed look I think
people just do it before they go out too
I tried doing it well it said that I
tried the self-driving Tesla and I did a
little sniff and then I went I'm not
going to sniff too deep while I'm
driving this I don't think you're
supposed to smelling salt and drive
I'm gonna take a really really big okay
wait hold on before you do that Dave
just text me if I use them quickly
enough they can prevent me from passing
out they wake you up when he's feeling
lightheaded yeah no but this is like
Todd thinks I should go to the coffee
shop too much so he's doing anything he
can to keep me away
he thinks I spent too much time there I
do I just start chatting
okay ready
all right you want to film it okay me
too I'm gonna take a really wait can we
someone set a timer for 10 seconds I'm
gonna take a 10 second inhale I'll do it
okay ready
so go
you guys I am freaking out I'm wearing
this product now I can't believe it I
was bragging it at Ulta I was at Ulta
bragging I was like they sponsor my
podcast everyone's like please ma'am
leave the building what are you doing
I love living living proof I honestly I
don't want to be rude to other uh dry
shampoos but you don't exist living
proof develops game changing
formulations that have raised the bar
when it comes tailored to Hair Care
performance unlike the other hair care
options living proof address is your
specific hair needs and concerns like
frizz
dullness and damage and offers unique
scalp Care Solutions because science in
action equals your best hair I like that
their thing is everything comes from the
lab like it is the it's created by
scientists so they are really creating
the best formulas they're dry shampoo it
it just blows all the other ones like
nothing
it's so good it's it's so amazing and I
yeah and there's no one-size-fits-all
solution when it comes to hair care I
know my hair gets really easily Tangled
but their conditioner I use the full
it's light and it gives me volume and
it's exactly what I need for my doll dry
hair I have to be honest in this and I
have not tried the shampoo yet I'm so
excited to try it I only use the dry
shampoo it's really good I'm so excited
it just it makes me feel so clean I just
use their Intense Moisture masks
so so so good my hair was so thirsty for
it and they also have the The Vanishing
oil have you tried that oh my God you
guys all these little like frizzy things
up here because I need that my hair is
the vanishing oil I swear to God just a
little dab and it takes all of the tiny
little frizz it's time to put science to
work and unlock your best hair with
living proof go to livingproof.com
Tuesday and use code Tuesday to get 10
off your first purchase that's
livingproof.com Tuesday code Tuesday for
10 off your first purchase
livingproof.com Tuesday coat Tuesday
okay this is our favorite
our favorite new sponsor I think this
was made for us it was made for us we're
so excited we're talking about Dipsy
everyone needs an escape but those can
be hard to come by right now enter Dipsy
let yourself get lost in a world where
good things happen and where your
pleasure is the only priority
Dipsy is an audio app full of short sexy
stories designed to turn you on each
Dipsy audio story features characters
that feel like real people and immersive
scenarios so you feel like you're right
there and let me say something I'm sort
of tired of this all-out explicit visual
stuff that I've been used to over the
years I actually want to Feast my ears
for once yes kind of scale it back a bit
bring it back to the old times where I
just closed my eyes and listen to
um a love story a meat cue a little
erotica I think this is huge like I I
don't know a single person that isn't
like so audibly turned on like I think
words can really take you there imagine
me driving over here with this Tesla
obviously hands-free
you guys can listen to stories about
hooking up with your hometown Crush you
never made a move on or that co-worker
you always had a little thing for you
imagine not making a movie imagine just
for one second not making the move they
release new content every week so
there's always more to explore no matter
what you're into or what turns you on
and if you need to wind down Dipsy also
has Wellness sessions sensual Bedtime
Stories and soundscapes to help you
relax before you drift off for listeners
of the show Dipsy is offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to dipsystories.com Tuesday that's 30
days of full access for free when you go
to d i p s e a stories.com Tuesday
foreign
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten oh
wow
I think I need to wait hold on what
I just knew it could hurt more Annie
I've never meant this in a better way
you are a beast this is what happens
when you have brothers in your mama's
short hair and you're just trying to
impress them
turns you into a monster would you like
to try I'm not going to inhale because
then oh my God I like can feel that in
my mouth from over here come here you
want to feel any more closer
I feel amazing are they bad for you
you're crying hysterically oh that's
rough the ammonia is rough oh it's let
me give it give me let me see how I
think I like it but can you get addicted
to it ammonia because it hurts so good I
don't think you're supposed to expose
yourself uh all day to ammonia Todd
wants it for editing it burns I know
it's good it's no cat piss it's the same
creep it into your [ __ ] yeah cat Kegel
put it I'm actually not kidding we're
doing that on the line I'm gonna try to
see the health benefit to this can I can
I eat your queef yes I'm gonna I'm gonna
Kegel it in and then I'm gonna push it
out into kalila's face I'm gonna get a
bikini wax for this oh my God it's
supposed to I'm in I'm in a very very
unconditionally loving relationship and
[ __ ] is just getting left behind a
combination of chemicals mix and release
small amounts of ammonia gas the ammonia
irritates the blood vessels in the nasal
passages providing an instantaneous
boost of strength energy and Focus what
if it just made me attack you
and then I start fingering you
oh also Carlos
but you gotta like it right but you kind
of like it but don't you guys like it
yeah it's like Wasabi yeah Esther have
you ever done a Revenge hookup oh a
Revenge hookup is like
um I'm gonna [ __ ] your boss I'm gonna
[ __ ] your dad I'm gonna [ __ ] your
brother it has to be someone in their
Circle or in their business
someone that you know it's gonna really
piss them off that you had sex with them
I'm here to say I've done a Revenge
hookup once
it's not it's not worth it it's you only
it makes you look like [ __ ] it makes you
feel bad yeah it's like yeah because all
of that is again this is like external
locus of control rate it's like wanting
that person to feel a way about you that
they obviously already don't because
they're they've already released you
from their life so then you're just
there banging their cousin they're like
okay it was I didn't do a family member
but it's like a pier is it like uh so
you just homie hopped
they weren't friends it's hard to say
this without being too specific home
home to the hop to the
Esther who so you yeah what was your
acquaintance hopped yeah this was like
years ago I was super young and I got
dumped and I was pissed and
there was someone it for me it was
someone I was interested in and I I part
of my motivation though to like steal
the deal right away with this person was
like I know this is a little revengey
but I it's not like I just did it for
that reason but that undertone was there
and I think that makes it like a
negative experience it's like like you
said like you don't get the result you
want from it and you're just kind of
like you're almost using yourself
you're using your body and yeah and I
was like I'm gonna go [ __ ] someone and I
was like wait that was me I did okay so
when I was like 21
I had moved back to Philadelphia
and I met this guy and we like had
hooked up and we we were like kind of
like writing comedy writing Partners or
whatever and we had hooked up and we're
kind of into each other and then he had
just gone through a breakup with like
his long-term girlfriend and she hit him
up and was like Hey I want to like
let's go out to eat like and see if we
want to get back together or whatever so
he was like what should I do he like
called me and I was like this I was so I
always broke down I always acted like I
didn't like guys I liked I was so like
afraid of being vulnerable and stuff for
so long in my life that I was just like
oh I don't care like whatever
I don't like you like that but I was so
into him you know so then he got back
with his girlfriend and then I was like
so kind of like ruined by it and we
would still hang out and like it was
just so like I felt so like he didn't
choose me but obviously looking back I
told him not to and um but I would hang
out with him and he lived with all these
guys in this house they all went to Penn
and um so I none of them knew I like had
hooked up with him really or that they
told me so I was just like a girl that
hung out with all these guys so like
they all would hit on me and stuff so I
just started hooking up with one of the
other friends but it was weird because I
was so into him you know and it was like
because I was pissed I was like what the
[ __ ] and you're like bringing her here
when I'm here yeah all this stuff but
looking back 100 my responsibility yeah
I totally did that and then I did end up
hooking up with the other there was like
I got a floor there was a floor in their
house that I hooked up with I didn't
[ __ ] them but I but I I only [ __ ] one
of them but that guy I [ __ ] him for a
long time I after he broke up with his
girlfriend he was like my in-betweenie I
love in between oh I have an Uber issue
here I want to talk about and see if you
guys have had this experience too
foreign
so I've been getting ubereats or uh
Postmates and I get the priority right
where you get it so you just know it's
coming from your house I got a lot of
soup okay I don't want things getting
great so it's their your house is their
first stop right now yeah you can't go
yeah but what they do is they're doing
four different apps
so your priority on that app but then
they don't know that you can see them
driving so I'm watching them Drive get
so close to my house then drive to West
Hollywood I'm like hello and then I'll
call like this one guy I was like can
you just come back I'm a big Tipper like
just get my food to me I I got it party
because I have to leave like I need it
you know and you pay extra it's only
like I don't know four dollars because
there's caviar there's GrubHub wait what
did they say and they go oh they don't
know that you can see them so I just
want to let you guys know we can see you
and you're I don't know how to get you
in trouble because you can't it's like a
robot but the guy was like and I still
want to tip I don't want to like not tip
people so I gave this guy Tiffany
because I don't understand why you're so
mad at me I had another order I go on
another app do you understand you were
and it's so weird because they always
are so close to your house when they hit
the call it's like just drop it just
come to one minute it'll be one minute
away and then it's like in 30 minutes
your food's gonna get there well then
especially it sucks if you're pretty
hangry because one minute to 30 minutes
is a is a long time but you've already
waited your sugar has dropped you
already need those smelling salts well
now we have the smelling sauce to get
through my my Postmates traumatic stress
disorder
here's a hot take I don't want a lover
to tell me he's proud of me why because
I've been yearning for so long I think
I've been urinated on I swear to God I
do have been urinated on we know this
the reason I don't want a man to say
he's proud of me is because it feels
like something I've been wanting to hear
from my parents for so long
I'm like if someone says they're proud
of me I'm like wait do I want to [ __ ]
you anymore you you just turned into you
know my ideal parents this is the crack
of the darkness we're seeing here this
is cool yeah that's interesting I
definitely Papa actually what's so crazy
is I literally asked Dave last night if
he was proud of me for how far I've come
and he explained my success the funniest
way he said it's not like you were here
and went here it's like you were it's
how low you were he's like you were down
here and now you're here and I'm like
that's true you know what they call him
a real hype man yeah that's how I met
because for Dave just imagine it's like
and you proud of me what should we ask
when I met Dave I was sharing a studio
apartment with oh my God she had a she
had to call Bobby and ask him if he's
proud of me yes I bet he is and then my
[ __ ] will go dry is what's going to
happen right well why did not we'll get
it wet again thank you we'll tell you
that I'm imagine me taking those
those hard bananas
hello
sweetie what are you proud of me
yeah
oh that's anticlimactic
well no ask me again
are you proud of me
[Laughter]
is he proud of us are you proud of
Esther and Annie
ah God it's a hard one but Bobby wait
can I give you a context
in contact yeah do you remember when I
when I was in the office of The Comedy
Store like four years ago telling me I
was living in my car and you were like
oh my God you're broke what's wrong with
you you need a podcast are you proud of
me now yeah but I didn't I don't that
never happened
with me I'm proud of you know Esther I
thought she was gonna die
because I just thought
she has no survival skills whatsoever
this one's gonna just wither away but
she kind of made it she's still around
Annie I didn't even think was human but
it turns out she is so that's a win
[Laughter]
Esther's Survivor skills is making me
think she doesn't have survival skills
yeah you are being recorded sweets why
are you call me baby get home I gotta
get to the Enterprise Rental okay bye I
love you bye quick I've got to get a
rental
you guys spring training is coming up
we're gonna go to a baseball game okay
all right I like baseball games yeah and
you get to cheer Esther that's what
you're good at
what Annie make the sound
charge
the credit card how embarrassing would
it be though if you and I tried to start
the wave and no one followed it would be
perfect life is for those how many more
times would we try
the whole time the whole thing is going
to be us hopefully getting rejected yeah
I know I was going to say that we gotta
try to get on the Jumbotron yeah
triple kiss oh also a fake we should
have like a fake big fight like pretend
like we're screaming at each other Well
here here's how that'll be believable if
you're wearing like a Cubs hat and I'm a
Dodger fan and just sit three three
seats away from me okay and this is what
happened on the airplane
did you guys sit together on the way to
New York no we didn't go together and
did you guys sit together
oh
my God
Carlos if you had [ __ ] blocked that oh I
want to say something a guy wrote me
with a very interesting question and I
guess I'll just um give you the gist of
it is that he doesn't have a foot fetish
but he likes girls with what are those
socks that only come to the no-show
socks but the color of the socks have to
be a very specific color they can't be
color block they can't have color like
past like mid foot or something like
that so what do we call that is that
just a sock fetish then
yeah very specific like like those
no-show socks just came out wait I
should his fetish was just created
oh wait and also they I can't imagine a
foot looking silly okay here let me just
read it then I'm curious what your
opinion or take on it on this is
um I heard at the end of the latest
episode you guys talking about men who
have foot fetishes I think I do but it's
only feet and socks also it's only
certain types of socks so like a bare
foot or bare feet do absolutely nothing
for me but I find it very attractive or
cute when a woman wears plain colored
ankle or no-show socks any solid color
besides black or gray so no black or
gray I also enjoy it if it has a brand
logo on it like Nike or
oh he's a fancy one I don't mind if
socks have a simple pattern on them
either but I hate capital h a t e when
socks have different color toe or heels
the cutest socks that have like a little
if he finds it repulsive and mid-calf
socks are knee-high or anything else I
don't remotely
find attractive I am inspired by how
specific right so weird it is it's like
you can really have whatever you want
and that's like so easy too like his
wife or girlfriend can just like very
easily just give him his well this
inspires me for an only fans because not
only would I not have to show my toes I
would just have to wear plain [ __ ]
no-show socks why are we doing it
because it cost me nothing to go yeah
you know what I mean I feel like you
could sell those stinkers for quite a
bit too
I do really wonder if we had on only
fans that it was not mainstream
pornographic
but subtle
sexy like kalila's feet in cute socks
yeah I guess that's like my feet yeah
she's the she's a sought after well it's
just because I won't let him have it
yeah that's why I think feet are like
they get you from point A to point B and
I don't need them to be pretty I just
want them to work okay I have a I have
an idea it's not about yeah listen it's
not about feet but I just from I just
got inspired can we please make let's
write a song and make a music video and
it's choreographed I'm obviously in
let's do it I've been in
yeah
yeah like he'll just lay down some
tracks yes and then let's like write the
lyrics and everything and I'm sure we
can get someone to make our voices sound
not bad and yeah and post yeah we don't
even need that let's release
Tuesday hit single
you know that is I feel like part of the
inspo in my mind for our show being
called trash Tuesday do you guys
remember going up new music Tuesday that
was like a huge thing in my life like
Best Buy would have the new albums come
out on Tuesday oh no one no one happy
drops on a Tuesday wow
um Carlos do you have any fan questions
wow oh wait I wanted to say we were
talking about unsolicited advice I think
the last episode of my episode before I
actually heard okay so I said that it's
like it's like almost a it's like a
criticism criticism however in the the
music the the baz Lerman sunblock song
he says that unsolicited advice is a
form of nostalgia that that person is
like going like I don't remember the
exact line will you look it up we just
look up Nostalgia and baslerman but it's
sweeter it's like sweet and then I was
like because I was I remember I had
Duncan Trust on my solo podcast back in
the day and he was taught we were
talking about when his wife was pregnant
like all these older women would like
want to give her advice and touch and it
was like it was like annoying to them
you know and I think a lot of pregnant
women have that feeling right but then I
was like think about it though like how
sweet that is too it's like they went
through this thing and they like want to
remember this remember remember and like
share it with you so I was like I want
to think about it that way rather than
it being is that why everyone was always
asking me when is my wedding are they
just thinking about their own because
that would make me feel so much better
well maybe this one I mean probably are
you that's what you're thinking about
when you ask people right
Todd one's like a really nice wedding
and I have no I just don't care I would
love to go to Vegas I feel like I wanna
I wanna get married by Elvis I'm
courtroom [ __ ] yeah courtroom
Courthouse courtroom Courthouse yeah
some of my most like amazing members at
weddings where my friend Abby and Pete
Van lewand Ice Cream the ones that did
like that we should get some I love van
Luen Pete give us some money and we'll
promote you for real uh
this is one freebie she's like one free
scoop no but remember when they had like
the macaroni and cheese kind or
something
but um so their wedding was just we all
went to college of Santa Fe together
dearly departed College went out of
business twice and then burned to the
ground
um but we went they got married at the
courthouse with like you know maybe 15
20 of us and then
um we like went up to the cross of the
martyrs which was just like this
cross-up like a little hike and it's
this beautiful cross and um
people they were drinking champagne and
stuff and then they rented this like
really cool Airbnb and everyone just did
mushrooms and had like the most amazing
it was just like such a fun wedding that
sounds really fun and it wasn't like it
wasn't on the weird like like it was
beautiful because I will say I don't
like I've been to several weddings and
big ones are never a core memory for me
right my favorite wedding that I
attended was of my aunt from Germany her
and her dude flew to Vegas and we were
in a chapel I was in like me and my
sister and I always were in club attire
like just really how outfits and I
couldn't have cried harder we were all
bawling our eyes off it was so that's a
core memory for me everything else every
other wedding like eh transactional
looks too big where's the [ __ ] bro
like the love is like the small little
part of it right and then the rest is I
used to be really embarrassed don't be
afraid to make some sounds Esther thanks
is it rude I need a snack no snack it up
babe listen we've got we've come so far
since the gum chewing we're all okay
um Carlos a question
oh yeah
hey ladies uh I'll keep it nice short
and simple I was just wondering if you
guys could give me your best the Esters
oh yeah oh my oh my thanks a lot I
appreciate it no that's on the live show
yeah
March March 30th 6 p.m Pacific time come
to us moment house.com trash Tuesday why
just about the voice note that Carlos
pulled like are you because that is so
annoying he's sexualizing us Carlos is
that what you want you want to hear us
I'll make that sound I'll do it for you
for free Carlos thank you on the live
[ __ ] shut your shut your esophagus or
whatever that sound comes from
close the hole clamp it April okay next
one
hi guys uh my name is April and I am
if you believe in ghosts
um psychics mediums
especially the people that say they've
been [ __ ] by ghosts
what are you thinking what are your
thoughts okay what are your stories
I'm just curious I I've been I've been
[ __ ] then ghosted
listen I don't ever want to be haunted
by a ghost but if a ghost were to feel
just like couldn't resist couldn't hold
back I'd just like to be sexualized by a
ghost I think in my sleep though make me
come though okay don't stop till you
make me come hard don't stop till you
make her come hard and fast policy here
which is that I've always believed since
I was little
their dog the ghosts like me I believe
in Spirit guides
hey guys uh [ __ ] Mary kill I think
that's it guys yeah I think that's it
for today I agree and we're not mad at
the questions we're mad at the question
picker
so Carlos would be killed
you guys thank you so much for listening
today and we love you we will see you at
the live show on March 30th go to
mommenthouse.com Tuesday for tickets and
don't forget to subscribe comment do all
the things we want to grow with you
we'll see you guys
next week
bye
[Music]